[Musik]
getestet und kein ergebnis
urlaubsheimkehrer bleiben lange im
unklaren bayern hat immer noch nicht
alle infizierten informiert protests und
gegenprotest in belarus bringt präsident
lukaschenko jetzt seine anhänger auf die
straße aber auch die opposition
demonstriert weiter lewis hamilton und
seine eigene liga der formel1 führende
ist beim großen preis von spanien nicht
zu schlagen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen guten
sonntagabend in allen hier ist ihr
nachrichtenüberblick in den kommenden
zehn minuten norbert könig hat den sport
in deutschland müssen immer noch viele
menschen viel zu lange auf ihre corona
testergebnisse warten
bayern hat es eine schwere panne mit
positivtests deren ergebnis an die
betroffenen lange nicht weitergegeben
wurde offenbar immer noch nicht voll im
griff
es müssten noch daten abgearbeitet
werden sagt das bayerische
gesundheitsministerium
eigentlich sollte das schon vor tagen
abgeschlossen sein
44.000 getestete reiserückkehrer hatten
lange kein ergebnis mitgeteilt bekommen
darunter auch fast 1000 die infiziert
sind petra neubauer
eigentlich hatte bayerns
gesundheitsministerin himmel versprochen
bis donnerstagmittag hätten alle positiv
getesteten ihr ergebnis doch gelungen
ist das bis heute nicht am nachmittag
heißt es es mussten zig tausende
dokumente gesichtet werden um die
getesteten ermitteln zu können das
gelang nun bei 903 betroffenen bei
lediglich 46 positiven befunden liegen
keine passenden personen daten vor
etliche male war die bekanntgabe dieser
zahlen verschoben worden
es war offenbar schwieriger als gedacht
ordnung in das wirrwarr zu bekommen
es war insgesamt ein dynamischer vorgang
so dass man eben jetzt lieber auf nummer
sicher gehen wollte und sagen wollte wir
machen da keine zwischenstände sondern
wir wollen jetzt uns auf die information
auf das abarbeiten konzentrieren
durch das eilige einrichten der
teststationen stand anfangs keine
software zur verfügung die
ehrenamtlichen helfer mussten die daten
der vielen test willigen händisch
eingeben
für bayerns regierung der grund für das
chaos die opposition aber vermisst im
ard-sommerinterview die weitsicht es
mindestens ein schweres versäumnis dass
wir in den sommerferien nicht das
urlaubs ende mit gedacht haben oder in
diesem fall die bundesregierung und das
jetzt alles heute die polter und über
nacht passiert und mit großen fehlern
passiert in bayern hat nun der private
dienstleister euro finstersten der
reiserückkehrer übernommen ganz digital
spätestens nach 72 stunden sollen alle
ihr ergebnis haben wieder ein
versprechen diesmal von eur
und die test panne kommt ausgerechnet zu
einer zeit in der nicht nur in bayern
viele menschen aus einer besonders
gefährdeten regionen zurück nach
deutschland kommen aus dem westlichen
balkan nämlich die meisten infizierten
sind laut robert koch institut in den
vergangenen vier wochen aus dem kosovo
eingereist mehr als 1000 zum vergleich
aus spanien kamen nur 107 infizierte
überhaupt gelten sechs länder in der
region als risikogebiete nur slowenien
und kroatien nicht
britta hilpert die rückreisewelle rollt
aus südosteuropa und einige heimtiere
nach deutschland haben wohl auch das
virus im gepäck denn nirgendwo im
ausland stecken sich urlauber häufiger
an als auf dem westbalkan
viele lassen sich deshalb testen ein
restrisiko bleibt immer auch also in
jedem land egal wie viel man sich
anstrengt deswegen war der test
notwendig ich bin jeden tag feiern
gegangen und so weiter enge gassen volle
strände party urlaub auf der insel park
österreich warnt bereits vor reisen nach
kroatien deutschland noch nicht aber
deutsche urlauber haben sich so schon
angesteckt doch laut lka komme die
meisten die sich außerhalb deutschlands
infizieren aus dem kosovo in den knapp
zwei millionen einwohner land verstorben
in einer woche 74 infizierte
das gesundheitssystem ist am limit die
hier typischen großfamilien hätten die
ausbreitung befördert erklärt professor
die menschen haben ihre familien besucht
oft ohne angemessene schutzmaßnahmen
das hat die ausbreitung des virus
befördert anstehen für den test gleich
nach der grenze kann dauern
aber es ist nun pflicht für die meisten
rückkehrer vom westbalkan weltweit
verbreitet sich das corona virus so
schnell wie noch nie innerhalb von 24
stunden wurden jetzt 300.000 neue
infektionen erfasst ein neuer höchstwert
meldet die weltgesundheitsorganisation
in deutschland haben sich in der letzten
woche im schnitt jeden tag 1000 80
menschen mit dem virus infiziert
unser nächstes thema ein jahr bis zur
bundestagswahl die spd hat schon anfang
der woche verkündet unser
spitzenkandidat heißt olaf scholz
das könnte zur internen zerreißprobe
werden die parteiführung eher links der
kandidat eher konservativ doch der spd
vorsitzende norbert walter borjans sieht
darin kein problem erklärt er im
zdf-sommerinterview das boot sagt es
sind sicher keine leichten zeiten für
die spd die ausrufen des
kanzlerkandidaten norbert walter borjans
aber einen ko er sei überzeugt dass olaf
scholz trotz einer nach links geschwenkt
spd genügend beinfreiheit habe es wird
kein programm geben das einen kandidaten
aufgestellt wird und auch nicht
koalitions verhandlungen die am
kandidaten aufgestellt werden sondern es
wird aber umgekehrt auch nicht so sein
wie das manche sich früher mal
vorgestellt haben man bestimmt einen und
er entscheidet dann was spd ist doch wie
einig sind sich die spitzengenossen
während sich der kanzlerkandidat
skeptisch zu einem bündnis mit der
linkspartei äußert zeigt sich der
parteivorsitzende offen
wir haben gemeinsam auch olaf scholz wie
sang gemeinsam ist es zeit dass in
deutschland die politik wieder
unterscheidbar wird dahingehend dass die
spd nicht mit der büro in einer großen
koalition nicht mit cdu und csu die
mehrheit sucht sondern mit anderen
walter borjans betonte im zdf
sommerinterview vor allem das
verbindende zur linkspartei
deren vorschlag die wochenarbeitszeit
auf 30 stunden zu verkürzen hält er für
diskussionswürdig wenn ich jedes mal das
was die konservative seite sage als der
weisheit letzter schluss sehen würde
dann hätten wir viele dinge die wir in
den letzten jahren erreicht haben nicht
erreicht und insofern muss man auch
wieder über arbeitszeit schauen wir mal
auf den allen umfragen zum trotz zeigt
der spd-chef einen fast schon stoischen
optimismus mit ihrem kandidaten so sagt
er könne die spd wieder 30 prozent holen
und das ganze interview können sie hier
im zdf sehen gleich nach uns und jetzt
die situation in belarus wo zehntausende
auf den straßen sind immer noch und
immer wieder
präsident alexander lukaschenko lehnt
jeden dialog ab und trommel zum ersten
mal seit der wahl eine demonstration
zusammen für sich selbst
die opposition fordert beim großen
marsch der freiheit wie sie sagt den
rücktritt des präsidenten für begann die
demokratiebewegung in belarus zeigt
keinerlei ermüdungserscheinungen im
gegenteil
der marsch für die freiheit zu dem die
opposition aufgerufen hatte entwickelt
sich zur bisher grössten kundgebung
gegen dauer präsidenten lukaschenko zum
ersten mal seit 26 jahren spüren wir
dass wir eine freie europäische nation
sein können wir sind viele und zusammen
werden wir gewinnen
ich kann alles verändern ruft die menge
in minsk an anderer stelle der stadt
sehr viel weniger menschen vier bis
fünftausend vielleicht bei einer
veranstaltung die lukaschenko regime
organisiert hat der autokrat verbreitet
falschmeldungen das nato-truppen sich an
der westgrenze bereit machten belarus
ins chaos zu stürzen ist eine dieser
haltlosen behauptungen neuwahlen lehnt
er weiter ab
wenn wir das machen würden werden wir
sofort in den sturzflug übergehen
dann können wir unser fluggerät nie
wieder stabilisieren
wir werden als staat sterben als volk
und als nation
unterstützung erhält der machthaber
heute aus moskau
der kreml teilt mit man werde
lukaschenko bei der lösung etwaige
auftretende probleme behilflich sein
das thema wird uns weiter beschäftigen
jetzt erst mal der sport und den hat
norbert im blick die champions league
dienstag mittwoch geht es weiter und die
profis von olympique lyon sind die
außenseiter im halbfinale aber wer den
britischen top club manchester city aus
der königsklasse befördert da dürfte
auch am mittwoch gegen den fc bayern
seine chancen haben der grosse favorit
am boden pep guardiola mal wieder nicht
im finale der champions league
manchester city verliert auch weil
dieses foul von moussa dembele an
laporte nicht gehandelt
der eingewechselte stürmer trifft frei
zum 2 1 in der 79 minute etwa später
auch noch zum 31 die engländer
enttäuschen spielen kompliziert und oft
harmlos erzielen nur ein tor zum
ausgleich von kevin de bruyne ansonsten
sind die franzosen wie man 100 einfach
präsenter gedankenschneller gewinnen
verdient mit 3 1 und treffen jetzt im
halbfinale auf den fc bayern
formel-1-weltmeister lewis hamilton
arbeitet weiter erfolgreich für seinen
siebten titel siegen barcelona und
sebastian vettel mit schadensbegrenzung
auf platz sieben
es hat etwas von hilflosigkeit als
sebastian vettel 13 runden vor schluss
von seinem renningenieur gefragt wird
was denkst du kannst du das rennen mit
den reifen zu ende fahren und er um das
antwortet genau das wollte ich vorhin
von euch wissen mit nur einem stopp und
abgefahrenen pneus rettete er rang
sieben ins ziel sein team konkurrent
hingegen scheidet aus ein dreher und
elektronikprobleme stoppen charles'
claire der kronprinz von förster binotto
ausgeschrieben
max verstappen holt sich die
ausgangslage für rang zwei direkt am
start überholt weiter reporters im
mercedes lewis hamiltons aufregendste
moment war die champagner-dusche musik
war dagegen ein klacks
tja die bleus die bleus beim club kino
werden
da schauen wir noch aufs wetter da gibt
es ganz aktuell eine warnung vor
schweren gewittern im südwesten von
deutschland und das hier ist die lage
morgen im osten sonne sonst aber viele
wolken mit schauern und auch heftigen
gewittern
das ganze bei 21 bis 32 grad dienstag
dann noch sehr wechselhaft danach aber
wieder freundlicher und auch wärmer so
das war's von heute 19 teams kleber
übernimmt dem heute journal um 21.45 und
er hat viele fragen an den
bundesgesundheitsminister
wir sehen uns auch morgen wieder aber
erst in allen einen angenehmen abend mit
dem zdf sommerinterviews